only on CBS this morning we traveled
with researchers on an extraordinary
mission to find a piece of American
military history lost deep in the South
Pacific yesterday we showed you how the
team went looking for the wreck of the
USS Hornet the Japanese sank the
aircraft carrier in October of 1942 as
Mark Phillips reported from somewhere
east of the solomon islands the
researchers discovered a big potential
clue
today he reveals what they found good
morning from the good ship petrol a boat
filled with high technology and cautious
hope they have found something down
there the question is is that what
they're looking for the research vessel
petrol is perched on a spot in the South
Pacific Ocean that was anything but
peaceful 77 years ago then it was the
scene of a major battle between the u.s.
and the Imperial Japanese Navy's the
battle raged without Blenheim the
morning
for the US aircraft carrier Hornets it
would be her lies about enemy planes
scored several hits on the Hornet when
they left we were dead in the water
Richard in the watsky 95 now was an 18
year old gunner on the Hornet they use
armor-piercing bombs now when they come
down you hear them going through the
decks plink plink plink plink and then
when they explode with 140 of her crew
already dead the order was given to
abandoned ship the Hornet went to the
bottom a bottom three and a half miles
down which the crew of the petrol has
been scanning with the deep-sea sonar
drone up on the top left what does that
look like the drone has brought back an
image of something down there that's
about the right size and about the right
place you can play hard together you say
that's it all right you know I'm tired
of eating straw hats still it's a
tempting target for mission chief Rob
Kraft let's go have a look ROV ROV
remotely operated vehicle latches open a
deep-sea sub lowered on a cable it's
full of cameras that send back live
pictures that bridge gonna give me a 50
meter movie West place and in the couple
of hours it takes to go down more than
17,000 feet there can be plenty to see
the shock you're gonna make sharks are
easy but what's that and way down where
the Sun never reaches what's that but
more to the point it's a really strange
signature what's that oh yeah oh wow oh
yeah it could be her lots of ships went
down around here come on a ship it is a
ship
they ship and it's big and if you see a
deck you know it's a carrier and if it's
a carrier it can only be the Hornet it
can only be the Hornet but what you need
is positive identification
the Hornets naval designation was cv8 yo
there's a there it is there it is where
we got it and there it was this is
everything this is Hornet this is Hornet
this is Hornet well done you got it in
one
you know one er huh we set up a video
link from the petrel to richard nawat
ski in california I can tell you now
that the petrol the ship that we're on
which has been looking for the Hornet
has in fact found it well we could even
show him the gun he was on during the
attack let's see this is right at the
stern of the Hornet where you were
stationed correct right if that's the
furthest 1/2 that but well that was my
gun looking at that now does it seem
like a familiar place yes it does
I used to stand on the right side of
that gun and that's where my equipment
was Wow well 77 years later there is you
down to my locker there's 40 bucks in it
you can have it Richard no Watsky has
enjoyed a long life since that day
seeing the Hornet again and the evidence
of the men who served a jacket hung on a
hatch
somebody's washed kit complete with
toothbrush naturally made him reflect on
those who hadn't been as lucky oh yeah
yeah that's true there were a lot of
young guys no I I know I've been a very
fortunate man the actual fact that you
can find these ships as mind-boggling to
me I want to thank you for honoring me
with this way
but it's the crew of the petrol and us
who are honored to find the Hornet and
the final resting place of so many of
her brave crew so another wreck another
war grave is discovered its exact
location kept secret to protect it but
the memory now has a place and the loss
a memorial it's fascinating to see that
minute right now the work that goes into
it